women's health research at Yale has a
training program that's called building
interdisciplinary research careers in
women's health and the focus of this
program is to train the next generation
of researchers on how to conduct team
science in order to increase their
capacity to move forward in their
research careers and to engage in team
science so women's health research at
Yale is really a national leader in
being able to train these junior
investigators in how to conduct research
that takes a more expansive focus then
their careers have taken previously so
it kind of takes them out of their
comfort zone and trains them on how to
engage researchers and other disciplines
to be able to start to collaborate to
put together teams of scientists to
address questions that they're
interested in pursuing
women's health research iel has provided
me as a junior faculty member with a
community of scholars and kindred
spirits so to speak so it's really
provided me with support not only
specific to my research in terms of
mentorship and expertise during the
perinatal period in psychiatry but it's
also provided a community of colleagues
where I can ask questions about career
development and also find support in
general around this area of work the
importance of women's health research
so your research needs to have real
world significance that you need to be
able to identify the work you do and how
it's ultimately going to be related to
the treatment of disease and this has
had a large impact on how i mentor
trainees in my own laboratory now how I
help them consider long-range plans for
their own careers and also always always
stress the practical benefit of their
own research
one of the most exciting things about
being a researcher and a teacher at a
university is that you get to introduce
young people to research and I've had
the good fortune of supervising dozens
of PhD students in my laboratory many of
them over half of them were women and
and it's particularly I think exciting
to those women to be able not only to
learn about this new field of biomedical
engineering and how one might use it in
in health but to think about how it can
be used to improve the health of women
we are only at the beginning of what we
need to know about women's health and
gender differences and so it's clear to
us that we need to train a next
generation of researchers will focus on
the area of women's health and we are so
pleased to have young scientists come to
us to study as junior faculty is
postdoctoral students as undergraduates
and we have many people interested in
doing that and its really been our great
pleasure to integrate them into our
program
you